Welcome students to
the pharmacology of
the anti-seizure drugs.
This is the first
of two parts. We'll
begin with the
introduction, which
I think of as the big
picture, and then
we'll talk about the
frequently used sodium
channel blockers.
Please do contact me
if you'd like a helping
hand with pharmacology
or just to chat
about it and tell me
everything you know.
Here are the
learning objectives.
I put headers on it
to help you catch the
gist of each of these
learning objectives.
Things that you
really need to know
to understand
the pharmacology.
And suggestions.
I do try and help
you with learning
methods to help
you retain the
information better.
My practice
questions, of course,
are full of click
case vignettes
to help you apply
the information
and let you know
what you know well
and what you'd
like to work on.
Here are links if
you'd like to use them.
Practice questions are
all that I require.
and the core principles
of anti-seizure drug
therapy to look at. As
you wish, I recommend
that you look at the
PowerPoint printout,
the PDF, before looking
at the video to give
yourself a general sense
of what the lecture
is about and the
background information.
The core principles
of anti-seizure
drug therapy
are here and we
will begin with
our introduction.
A seizure is a
paroxysmal event due to
abnormal excessive
or synchronous
neuronal activity in
the brain. Epilepsy
is a condition in
which a person has
recurrent seizures
due to a chronic
underlying process and
the causes are very
many and diverse
infection, trauma,
neoplasm, toxic
substances,
genetic predisposition
can all be
causes of epilepsy
or seizures.
Classification and the
general classifications
are here on this
slide. Focal onset
seizures and we'll be
talking about drugs
specifically for these in
this Part 1. Focal onset
seizures arise from
excessive, high-frequency,
abnormally synchronous
neuronal activity
within a specific,
discrete, local population
of neurons in one
cerebral hemisphere.
Neuronal
hyperexcitability and
hypersynchronous activity
due to localized,
rapidly firing,
voltage-gated
sodium channels. And
that's the hallmark
of these focal
onset seizures.
Focal seizures can
also evolve into
bilateral, tonic
-clonic seizures.
primary generalized
onset seizures arise in
both hemispheres
simultaneously often
involving deep brain
structures like the thalamus
and brainstem and
widespread cortical
networks the balance
between excitation and
inhibition across both
sides of the brain is
disrupted so we have
our Focal onset seizures
are primary generalized
onset seizures and
it is essential to be
able to differentiate
these in order to
understand why certain
drugs are chosen to
treat certain seizures.
I've listed here some
primary generalized
onset seizures that
I'll briefly mention as
we go along. Now,
status epilepticus is
operationally defined
as five minutes or more
of continuous seizure
activity or two or
more discrete seizures
between which there
is incomplete recovery
or consciousness.
So we will be
talking about drugs
specifically for
the management
of status
epilepticus as well.
We always need
to know what
are the goals
of our therapy.
Whatever our
therapy is, in
this case it's
drug therapy.
So the goals of
therapy of our
anti-seizure drugs is, of
course, controlling
the seizures,
also avoiding treatment
side effects, and
maintaining or restoring
quality of life. I'm
sure you recognize
that these would be the
goals of therapy for
any type of disorder.
the therapy must be
individualized just
as true with any therapy
treat the underlying
conditions as I
mentioned before
seizure disorders can
be caused by a different
underlying conditions
and if we know
what it is and we know
that's causing the
seizure and we know
we can treat that and
that would certainly
be the first step.
To avoid precipitating
factors, preventive
therapy or maintenance
therapy for
suppression or
recurrent seizures, and
then patient
-specific issues of
addressing psychological
and social issues.
Epilepsy is a difficult
disease to live with.
And with regard to
therapy selection, the
seizure classification
and an accurate
diagnosis is essential.
As I mentioned earlier,
different drugs
are used for
different types
of seizures, so an
accurate diagnosis
must be obtained.
These drugs act in
the central nervous
system, and they
have the potential
for numerous
adverse effects,
CNS effects and
peripheral effects.
It's important
to consider
comorbid medical
conditions.
Not only hepatic
and renal disease
that we always think
about for clearance
issues, but other
organs as well.
Interactions naturally
with other medications,
and some of these
have high potential
for drug interactions
and the age and
*** of the individuals
and whether or not
the patient has any
childbearing plans.
Lifestyle, patient
preferences, and cost.
Adequate drug
exposure must be
maintained continuously
to prevent seizures.
Patient Adherence
is important.
Adjusting dosages
Frequency of dosing
is important.
Fortunately,
all but one at
therapeutic levels follow
first-order kinetics,
and we will begin with
the drug that follows
zero-order kinetics.
This is the big picture
on seizure drugs,
and what types of
seizures they treat.
I've put stars on the
drugs that you should
know by name. You
can see that it's
slightly over half of
the drugs, maybe half,
on this list. There
are approximately 25
anti-seizure drugs
available at this time.
so what is the common
thread that connects
this diverse group of
anti-seizure drugs well
to be able to interrupt
and prevent seizures
they protect by interacting
with one or more
molecular targets so
a common thread is
acting on molecular
targets in the brain to
inhibit the generation
of seizure discharges.
So how is this done?
I've indicated here
the basic ways,
which is reducing the
ability of the
neurons to fire action
potentials at a high
rate. That makes sense.
Reducing neuronal
synchronization. Inhibiting
the spread of
epileptic activity to
nearby and distant sites.
And how is that done?
by strengthening
the inhibitory side,
which is the GABAergic
interneuron activity,
or inhibiting the
excitatory side,
the glutamate
-mediated transmission.
And potassium
channels will lead to
hyperpolarization,
which is inhibition,
so stabilizing
membrane potential via
potassium channels.
That is a relatively
small approach in
terms of the number
of drugs that do this.
I'm not going
to be including
these drugs,
but I will be
talking about all
of the others.
So the three major
categories are
voltage-gated
sodium channels.
And I'll go into
that mechanism
in more detail
in this lecture.
stopping the T-type
calcium currents,
and, as I
mentioned before,
strengthening
the GABA side and
inhibiting the
glutamate side.
The most common
anti-seizure drugs
follow sodium or
calcium channel
modulation. Those are
the biggest classes.
This is just a
look at all of the
potential molecular
mechanisms of the anti
-seizure drugs. I'm
not going to go
through each and every
one. I do encourage
you to look closely
at this slide
and at all of these
various mechanisms.
I will be touching on
them. But the takeaway
for this big picture
molecular targets
is that the
mechanisms usually are
identified in controlled
in vitro studies
and then tested in
rodent seizure models.
It is not proven
that these mechanisms
contribute to anti-seizure
activity in humans.
but the drugs are
chosen based on
studies that demonstrate
the evidence of
their clinical
efficacy for specific
seizure types or
epilepsy syndromes.
So clinical efficacy
But how do we know
what they do in vitro
studies, followed
by animal models?
So we know what
the mechanisms
are in these
early studies.
And it's inferred
that these
mechanisms contribute
to the anti
-seizure activity
in humans.
We don't know that
for sure, though.
So let's take a look at
the class pharmacokinetics
and the relevance
to patient care.
When I talk about
pharmacokinetics,
it's always so you can
understand why
we need to know
pharmacokinetics
in order to
take care of
our patients.
So management of
seizure disorder
is going to be a
long-term process.
So the drugs
that are useful
should be able to
be taken ******.
Drugs that are needed
for an acute response
should be able to be
given intravenously
and should have a rapid
onset when they are.
Other routes, we
have intramuscular,
intraosseous,
intranasal, ******,
if an IV axis cannot
be obtained. So
we have lots of
ways to introduce
the drugs into the
patient's system.
A lot of them are highly
plasma protein bound.
They all distribute
to the CNS, of course,
because that's where
the site of action is.
And therefore,
they're all widely
distributed
throughout the body,
central and
systemic effects.
most of them undergo
hepatic metabolism
many of them have
active metabolite active
metabolites many
of them have a high
potential for drug drug
interactions based on
enzyme inhibition
or induction the
bioavailability is good
fortunately for all of
them really and except
for one of the One,
this good
bioavailability will
provide predictable
blood levels.
Predictable is key
because when we
start a dose or
adjust a dose, we need
to be able to expect
a certain response
based on predictable
blood levels.
Many of them, most
of them, undergo
hepatic clearance.
Some of them, and
most of them, the
metabolites will be
excreted in urine.
Some of them have
some amount of
active drug in urine.
And drug-specific
half-lives, some have
short half-lives. That
requires frequent daily
administration. Some
have longer half
-lives. And those with
the shorter half-lives
often come in extended
release versions.
so that the drug
needs to be taken less
frequently than the
immediate release.
And that can hopefully
improve patient
adherence to taking
the medication.
Pharmacogenomics.
We have some
very important
issues here.
We have a couple of
immune-related variant
alleles that we need
to remember about.
HLA-B-star-1502, this
is carbamazepine,
and it's congeners,
carbamazepine,
phenytoin and
lamotrigine.
So why is this
important? Because
individuals who have
this variant allele
have a greater
frequency of severe
cutaneous adverse
reactions. Severe
reactions, which of
course has received
an acronym SCAR.
What are these reactions?
Stevens-Johnson Syndrome
Toxic Epidermal
Necrolysis.
We've talked
about this before,
this particular reaction.
It is severe, acute,
and life-threatening.
It affects the
skin and mucous
membranes. It's a
hypersensitivity reaction.
It is delayed.
It can occur one to four
weeks after
starting the drug.
And SJS has a mortality
of around 10% and
toxic epidermal
necrolysis of about 30%.
very, very important
adverse effects. So who
is at risk? It's
patients of various and
Asian ancestry. So the
recommendation before
starting this therapy
is for people who are
at risk to get a
screening to see if they
carry the HLA-B star
1502 variant allele.
And another one,
HLA star 3101
variant allele. This
is carbamazepine,
and its daughter,
oxcarbazepine,
or cousin, or
however you want
to think about
the related drug.
This is so
strongly associated
with DRESS, drug
reaction with
eosinophilia and
systemic symptoms.
It is what it sounds
like. It's the
various organ involvement,
the organ of the
skin and the visceral
organs. This allele
is found in, is more
widespread. It's
found in more
populations, European,
Japanese, Korean,
Chinese, South Asians.
And this is related
to carbamazepine
in particular and
oxcarbazepine.
Please do remember those.
So some big picture
adverse effects,
Toxicity potential,
the therapeutic
index for most of
the anti-epileptic
drugs, anti
-seizure drugs, is
low. And toxicity
is not uncommon.
It's common.
Withdrawal,
gradually taper,
reduce the dose
gradually over time
to minimize the
potential of increased
seizure activity.
If that drug is
abruptly withdrawn,
the patient can
suffer seizures.
Suicidal ideations.
This has long
been attached to
various CNS drugs.
The anti-seizure
drugs, the
antidepressants,
the anti-psychotics.
With continued study
of this particular
adverse effect over
time, The question is
raised whether or not
these suicidal ideations,
which can exist, is
a consequence of the
drug therapy or of
the seizure disorder.
In any case,
patients, particularly
younger patients,
should be observed for
particular suicidal
ideations. Now,
pregnancy. Well, this is
a chronic condition.
Epilepsy seizure disorder
is a chronic condition,
and individuals
who become pregnant
need to be treated.
So, what drugs
are more likely
to not cause harm
to the fetus?
Because with certain
of them, there is
increased risk of
congenital malformations.
which I'll talk about
in the next slide.
So folic acid and
vitamin K supplements
are recommended for
individuals who intend
to become pregnant
and who are pregnant.
What about the
youngsters,
infants and children?
The many seizure
disorders are
seen in the
pediatric population.
So in terms of
pharmacokinetics,
they have larger
volumes of
distribution in the
neonates and infants,
and especially
young children.
And in addition, the
neonate has immature
metabolic and
elimination capabilities.
So dosing must be
done by individuals
who are neonatologists
and understand how
to dose anti-seizure
drugs neurologists.
geriatrics well the
older patient first of
all has physiologic
changes and that can
vary depending on the
age of the patient the
the status physical
status of the patient
and also comorbid
conditions most older people
have some sort of
comorbid conditions and
some people have a
number of comorbid
conditions. So now we
really do have to think
about drug interactions
because older patients
tend to be on a
number of medications.
But not only older
patients. People who have
seizure disorders
may be on one or more
anti-seizure drugs and
other types of drugs.
this chart from
up to date shows
various studies
what various studies
have found in terms
of major congenital
malformation
rates this is for
monotherapy just the
one drug at a time
first i'd like to point
out that valproate
has the has shown the
highest potential for
major malformations
valproate should be avoided
if possible sometimes
it can't be avoided
the individual is
well controlled on
valproate so that has to
be a discussion with the
patient We have
phenobarbital, also relatively
high, phenytoin,
also relatively high,
and look at these
various studies have this
big difference in the
confidence intervals,
carbamazepine and
topiramate. So I put
a box, this box with
this broken line
around it, to point
out to you the
drugs that really
should be avoided in
individuals of
childbearing potential
who are being
initiated on therapy.
If the patient is
already on these
drugs and well
-controlled, old,
then, as I said before,
you have a conversation
with the patient
about it.
Levateracetam,
lamotrigine, and
oxcarbazepine have
been shown to be
relatively okay
for patients who
are planning on
becoming pregnant.
High potential for drug
interactions.
You're going to hear
me say this a
number of times.
Inducers, the CYP3A4
and other CYPs
and UGTs and P
-glycoproteins and
organic anion
transporters and so on.
I had you memorize a
list of inducers and
now we get to apply
it to the pharmacology
of drugs we're
learning about, these
anti-seizure drugs.
So what were they?
Phenatoin, carbamazepine,
phenobarbital.
Primidone is related to
phenobarbital, and
oxcarbazepine and
eslacarbazepine are
related to carbamazepine.
Valproate is
an inhibitor.
and then many of the
other anti-seizure
drugs may be affecting
the metabolic
enzymes either by
inducing them or
inhibiting them either
weekly or moderately
in any case this is
something that you
can look up in the
drug monograph when
the time comes that
you are faced with
patients who are
taking these drugs.
I'm personally
thinking about
your clinical rotations.
So withdrawal.
Discontinuation of
anti-seizure drugs
may be considered in
adults and children
who are seizure
-free for two years
or longer. That's
a recommendation.
They need to be slowly
tapered, usually
over several
weeks, even months.
there is no data to
indicate what the optimal
tapering regimen
the neurologist will
have experience at this
with this neurologists
are the ones who use
these drugs abrupt
cessation may be
associated with a return of
seizures even a risk
of status epilepticus
some drugs are more
easily withdrawn than
others and that's going
to depend on their
half-lives on how
long the patient's
been on the drugs and
various other factors
what about physical
dependence well
we we've talked
about benzodiazepines
or have we perhaps
we haven't yet
uh tolerance
can develop to
benzodiazepines and
also to barbiturates
But we have talked
about tolerance.
So here we are now
with our voltage
-gated sodium
channel inhibitors,
which is the topic
of this part one.
I've separated it
into two groups.
Put a line down
here if you like.
The fast inactivation
enhancers.
You see that's the
majority of them.
and another one called
this one has a star
on it lycosamide
is known as a slow
inactivation enhancer
and then we have
rafinamide which i'm not
going to go into which
also stabilizes an
inactivation site
the exact mechanism
really isn't clear so
let's talk about
sodium channels a bit
First, we need to
know how they actually
work, and this little
cartoon can be helpful
in giving you the
basic idea of them.
So physiologically,
they're in a closed
resting state. They're
resting. Nothing
is flowing through
the channel. Now, when
the depolarization
hits the threshold,
the channel undergoes a
conformational change,
and it opens, and
sodium flows through.
And then, it
quickly undergoes a
gating. You see
this gating here?
This is called the
open and inactivated
state. It's open
because sodium is able
to flow into the
channel, but again, the
sodium doesn't
actually go all the way
through because of the
gate on the bottom.
It's inactivated.
And this
allows for a
refractory period.
Then the cell repolarizes
to the threshold
voltage, and it can
be activated again.
So that's the basic
idea, basic physiology.
So the drugs that
are fast inactivation
enhancers, that's
what we're talking
about here, they
inactivate this portion
here. They bind to
a site in the sodium
channel. They have
to first get inside
the cell and they bind
inside and they hold
it in this open and
activated state.
So that's causing it
to be stabilized in
this state. In other
words, to stay in
that state for a
longer period of time.
And because a number of
sodium channels
are firing,
the drug will
accumulate block during
this repetitive
firing. And that's a
good thing. And then
the drug will bind
more strongly at
depolarized potentials.
So, we have the state
-dependent block,
open and inactivated,
we have use
-dependent block during
repetitive firing,
and we have voltage
-dependent block, binds
more tightly at
depolarized potential.
So that we see
with the phenytoin,
carbamazepine, and its
congeners, and lamotrigine.
Now, licosamide
is known as a slow
inactivation enhancer
because a slow
inactivation state is
actually a mechanism
for regulating
excitability by reducing
sodium influx. So a
neuron that remains
depolarized during
this repetitive firing
or this pathologic
hyperexcitability
enters a gradual
shift to a stable non
-conducting state and
this is called slow
inactivation and it
occurs over seconds.
Compare that to less
than a millisecond
with the fast
inactivation and this will
involve a conformational
change in the pore.
So, glucosamide is a
drug that will bind
to the channel at
the slow inactivation
state and that will enhance
state, stabilize
the sodium channel
for a long-lasting
non-conductive state.
So those are the
basic ideas now about
the sodium channel
blocking action.
It's about enhancing
inactivation time.
This is how sodium
channels work. I put
it here in case you
want to get more
familiar with the
sodium channel and its
components and where
the drugs bind and
all of that. I'm not
going to go through
this with you. I'm
not going to test
you on this, but it
really is helpful
for understanding
about sodium channels.
So let's talk now
about phenytoin.
Phosphenytoin is
a prodrug. As you
can see from the
name, it's got
phosphate on it.
And we'll talk about why
that's there in
the next slide.
So So phenytoin is an
enhancer of the fast
inactivation state.
Preferentially binds
a site within the
pore of the channel
when the channel is
open and inactivated.
Stabilizes the channel in
the open and
activated state.
Accumulates block
during repetitive
firing. Binds more
strongly at depolarized
potentials, so we
have state dependent,
use dependent,
and voltage
dependent activity.
I'm not going to test
you on the structures.
It's hard to tell
from these flat
two-dimensional
structures, but in 3D space
they will fit into
the sodium channel.
Now the pharmacokinetics
of phenytoin is
really important to
understand and I've
got two whole
slides just on the
pharmacokinetics because
it is that important
for patient care. So
first of all oral,
okay good,
sodium salt or phenytoin
base and phenytoin
base simply means
that it's just
plain phenytoin. It's
not in a salt form.
In this case, phenytoin
would be in a
sodium salt.
It's actually an
acid. Phenytoin is
a weak acid, and
it's got a high pKa.
So, in solution,
well, actually,
it doesn't go
into solution.
Therefore,
it has to be formulated
together with
propylene glycol,
look at that, 40% of
the product is
propylene glycol, plus
alcohol, another 10%,
and then the whole
thing gets adjusted
to a pH of 12 in order
to keep it in
solution in an IV bag.
Additionally,
it shouldn't be
given IM because it
will precipitate in
the tissues which
is irritating and
painful and harmful.
And on top of that
it's not well absorbed.
It's not absorbed
slowly and radically.
So enter phosphenatoid.
Phosphenatoid,
they form with the
phosphate on it doesn't
need to be formulated
with poly sorry
propylene glycol
and alcohol and
adjusted it to pH it's
ready to go it can
be put into an IV bag
and it will go into
solution so it's
safer for IV use
and safer for IM use
now let's talk
about these oral
products for a
moment the base
is really erratically
absorbed it comes in
chewable tablets and
suspension so if you
think about chewable
tablets and you think
about suspension you're
probably thinking
about oh that it would
be a good way for kids
to be taking the drug
yes and that's true
unfortunately the
absorption can be very
erratic with the
phenytoin base this free
acid form just because
of the particles
of various features
you don't have to
memorize those just
remember please that it's
uh got this erratic
absorption so if you
see such a big range
of absorption then
you say to yourself
gosh i wonder how
predictable those blood
levels are now the
sodium salt which
comes in capsules is
really has really good
absorption but But
the issue now becomes,
if the patient is
getting the sodium
salt and gets switched
over to the acid or
the other way around,
the patient, for
example, learns
how to swallow
capsules and gets
switched over
to the capsules,
then there needs to
be an adjustment made
based on bioavailability.
So that's all I'm
going to say about that.
That's why we care.
Distribution.
Well, naturally,
it goes to the
brain, also liver,
muscle, fat, wide
distribution,
high plasma
protein binding,
narrow therapeutic
window,
high plasma
protein binding,
narrow therapeutic
window.
We have to think
about potential drug
interactions related
to protein binding.
Conditions that
increase free
phenytoin, free
phenytoin levels
can increase
toxicity risk.
And you will see
that this drug is
associated with
numerous toxicities.
So what can cause
an increase in free
phenytoin levels?
levels. So
hypoalbuminemia, we have
low serum albumin. So
remember, it's
highly protein bound,
mainly to albumin.
So if we don't
have as much albumin
around, we're
going to have
higher free levels.
And this can occur
in liver failure,
nephrotic syndrome,
nephrotic, nephron,
nephron, that
sounds like kidney.
And that's where
it's a kidney disease
where protein gets lost
right into the urine.
So it goes out of the
blood, low albumin,
burns because of
capillary leakage,
pregnancy because of
a larger blood volume,
age just because
certain patients
are going to have
different albumin
levels based on
neonate to elderly.
And then we have
to think about
displacement. So
uremia, this is a kidney
failure in which we
get an accumulation
of nitrogenous waste
products, which
can get carried
around on the albumin,
which can displace
then the phenytoin.
And hyperbilirubinemia,
bilirubin
travels around
on the albumin
binding sites.
And then drug
interactions, of course.
Now looking at
metabolism, I'll come
back to the recap
when I get done.
cyp2c9 that's the
certainly the majority of
the drug gets metabolized
by that enzyme
and 2c19 good
bioavailability so it's a low
hepatic extraction
ratio it goes around
and around and eventually
gets metabolized by
these iso enzymes
so the takeaway with
metabolism is that
CYP2C9 inhibitors or poor
metabolizers will have
reduced metabolism,
therefore increased
drug levels,
toxicity risk.
And since this
is zero-order
pharmacokinetics,
it makes dosage
adjustment a little
complicated. it.
Additionally,
phenytoin is a strong
inducer of all of
these various proteins,
CYP2C9, CYP2C19,
CYP3A4, P-glycoprotein,
UDP
-glucuronosyltransferases,
especially 1A1, which is
one of the major ones.
Now, what if
CYP2C19 is also
inhibited by some
reason or another?
80 to 90 percent, 10 to
20 percent. My goodness,
that is definitely
going to
increase the
toxicity risk.
So what do we do about
it? Well, we look.
We see what the
free phenytoin
levels are. We
can measure that.
So that will
help with dosing.
Excretion of
the glucuronide
metabolites, not
much, if any,
active phenytoin gets
excreted in the urine.
So increased
refraction may occur
in patients with
altered kidney or
liver function. We
talked about the
mechanisms on the
previous slide.
zero order kinetics.
I'm sure you
remember about
that. The half
-life is dependent
on the plasma
concentration.
As the concentration
gets above the Km
and the metabolic
processes are saturated,
the drug levels
will just keep going
up as long as the
drug keeps going in.
So half-life is dependent
on the plasma
concentration.
At zero-order
kinetics, the drug
just gets metabolized
at the rate
that the metabolic
enzymes can go.
And once it gets
significantly
below the KM,
then we will see
first-order
metabolism. This
chart here shows
the inter-individual
differences in
phenytoin metabolism.
So I'll read this part
to you. The figure
shows the relationship
between serum
phenytoin concentration
and daily dose in five
patients. One, two,
three, four, five.
Each point represents
the mean of
three to eight
separate measurements
of phenytoin at
steady state.
So what it's
showing is that
saturation points
differ between
patients. So for
this patient,
just barely into
the therapeutic
window here at
approximately 100.
And here at
approximately 150, it's
approaching the
toxicity stage. compare
this to the one
on the right hand
side where it's
just barely reaching
the therapeutic window
at about 450 450
and the toxic range
at about 575 so
you can see there's
a huge difference.
So that's making dosing
unpredictable when
initiating therapy,
when changing the dose.
Okay, here are some
clinical correlates
related to the
pharmacokinetics of phenytoin.
Loading doses,
IV or oral,
are used to
rapidly achieve
therapeutic
concentrations. Okay,
same as any loading dose.
Cautious adjustment
of subsequent doses
is recommended
because with each
subsequent dose, we
can't be sure of what
blood level will
be achieved by it.
Several weeks may be
required to reliably
assess the results
of dosing changes
because of the time
to reach steady state,
which increases as
the dose increases
because of the non
-linear kinetics.
maintenance doses
but not loading doses
should be lower in
patients with liver
failure which causes
reduced metabolism and
hypoalbuminemia makes
sense doesn't it
patients with liver
failure hypoalbuminemia
i mentioned reduced
drug metabolism
and patients with
kidney failure
we're worried about
nephrotic syndrome
which is a protein
losing syndrome
and uremia, so
the buildup of the
nitrogenous wastes
that can displace
phenytoin from the
protein binding sites.
What do we use it
for? Well, focal onset
seizures, really. That's
the only thing that
it's useful for, and
particularly the type that
are the impaired
awareness arising from the
temporal lobe. It's
very, very effective
for that. But it can
be used to treat other
focal onset seizures,
including those evolving
to the generalized
tonic-clonic seizures.
And it's useful for
status epilepticus. Now
you may recall I said
it's got a pretty slow
onset of action, including
with IV infusion.
And I'm introducing
you here, introducing
to you this idea of
continuous cardiac
monitoring with IV phenytoin.
Now, why would that
be? Well, it's a
sodium channel blocker.
And it just so happens
that phenytoin has
anti-arrhythmic
activity like lidocaine.
And in fact, it was
formerly used for
digitalis intoxication,
but it's not anymore.
it can also be used
for the prevention and
treatment of seizures
occurring during or
following neurosurgery
okay so phenytoin
is efficacious what's
the problem toxicities
and complex
pharmacokinetics limit its
use phenytoin has been
around for nearly 90
years in clinical
practice for 90 years.
And so there's great
experience with its use.
But since then,
many drugs have been
developed that are much
less complex to use.
So phenytoin,
while it still has
an important
place in therapy,
is not the first
line any longer.
Major side effects.
Gosh, look at the
side effects all over the
place hypersensitivity
so here we have
our 1502 our HLA
B star 1502 SJS TEN
fever that comes with
the severe toxicities
severe skin
toxicities folic acid
deficiency because it it
really reduces the
absorption, increases
the breakdown of
folic acid. That can
lead to megaloblastic
anemia. How do we
manage that? Folic
acid supplementation.
Vitamin D deficiency.
Why? Because of
induction of hepatic
vitamin D breakdown.
So with vitamin D
deficiency comes impaired
bone mineralization,
rickets in kids,
osteomalacia in
older patients,
weakening of the bones.
Cosmetic side
effects, well, they're
not serious and
harmful, but they're
certainly concerning
to patients.
Gingival hyperplasia,
where the
gums grow down
over the teeth.
Coarsening of
facial features,
hirsutism, body
hair growing.
And then we have our
neurotoxic effects,
the nystagmus and
double vision.
The ataxia,
which is a gait
disturbance and
slurred speech.
Sedation at
higher levels.
Generally, there's
no sedation at
the usual
therapeutic levels.
And neuropathy
with long-term use.
Distal sensory loss.
Lower extremity
areflexia.
Polyneuropathies.
Fortunately,
those are really rare.
Infusion-related side
effects. Extravization.
Purple glove syndrome.
you may notice that I
put that in lavender
to help you remember
purple glove
syndrome cardiovascular
side effects hypotension
bradycardia heart
block ventricular
tachycardia and
fibrillation let's break
this down a bit as
I said it's a sodium
channel blocker So
that can slow the
activity through the
heart, slow the beat,
slow the conduction.
And that's the point
of it as an anti
-arrhythmic. That's the
point of anti-arrhythmics.
But like all
anti-arrhythmics,
it can cause arrhythmia.
Heart block,
ventricular tachycardia,
and fibrillation.
Now, the
hypotension, where
is that coming from?
That's coming from the
propylene glycol solvent,
which is known to
be a vasodilator
and a cardiac depressant.
Phosphenatoin can
be safer to use. It
will still have these
cardiac effects.
But generally, the
drug can be given
at a somewhat more
rapid intravenous
infusion, which is
good for onset, as long
as it's at recommended
rates. I mean,
it still has to be
a slow infusion.
And it doesn't
have the propylene
glycol solvent,
so it doesn't
have that
hypotensive effect.
Some pictures of
these various adverse
effects, the
gingival hyperplasia,
Stevens-Johnson syndrome,
hirsutism, this is a
woman who's just growing
a lot of hair on
her face that she
wouldn't normally have.
purple glove syndrome.
This is obviously a left
hand. We see some edema.
Let's see the spot here
that shows pitting edema.
The purplish coloration
and there are no
blisters that we see.
And the mechanism is
not 100% clear.
This is a picture of
osteomalacia, actually
vitamin D resistant
rickets in this patient
who was receiving
phenytoin actually
I'm not sure it was a
patient receiving phenytoin
but it's certainly
vitamin D resistant
rickets this is
megaloblastic anemia
with the hyper segmented
neutrophil that is
seen this can generally
be avoided with folate
supplementation.
And now in
pregnancy, something
called the fetal
hydantoin syndrome.
Fenytoin is a hydantoin
drug chemically.
Estimated 2.4-fold
increased risk for
any major malformation
in children with
prenatal exposure
compared to controls.
And this is based
on a meta-analysis.
The specific
fetal defects,
intrauterine
growth retardation,
abnormalities
of skull and
facial features,
cleft palate,
microcephaly,
mental retardation,
and underdeveloped
nails of the fingers
and toes. That's what
you see on the lower
figure. with regard
to nursing the infant
some of the drug
will be excreted in
breast milk it's not
a huge amount but some
authorities recommend
against breastfeeding
that's a conversation
between the
neurologist and the
mother of the child
so there is a mnemonic
for phenytoin side
effects that I found on
the internet might help
you with spelling out
phenytoins and I put
cardiovascular on
the bottom because we
can't forget that and I
put the mechanism here
so I encourage you to
take a look at this
Perhaps you want to
pause the video and take
it in. It's everything
we just talked about.
So now we have some
check your knowledge.
Fill in the column
on the right. And
this is the takeaway of
these pharmacokinetic
properties. So
with regard to oral
formulations having
slow erratic absorption,
it's difficult to
protect the effect
of the phenytoin
-based formulations.
And IV?
Well, phenytoin is
a highly alkaline
solution with propylene
glycol and alcohol.
Slow infusion
into a large vein
can cause severe
local irritation,
close monitoring for
extravasation, and
it can precipitate
in an intramuscular
injection, so it
shouldn't be done.
Phosphenytoin is
preferred. It's water
-soluble, faster infusion,
safer, rarely irritating,
and it can be given
IM if necessary.
Well, what about
plasma protein binding?
Conditions that
increase free phenytoin
level, increased
toxicity risk,
low albumin,
and displacement
from protein binding.
And metabolism, we
have our CYP2C9,
2C19, a little bit of
3A4. But the important
issue here is that
the drug is an
inducer of all of
these various proteins,
strong inducer. And
if its own metabolism
is inhibited,
then the phenytoin
levels, pre-phenytoin
levels can rise.
What about clearance?
Clearance is not constant
because of zero
-order kinetics.
And it's nonlinear.
A small change in
dose results in a
disproportionately
large change in
serum concentration.
And what about the half
-life? It's variable
because of the zero
-order kinetics.
Elimination half
-life increases
with increasing
concentration.
In other words, it
takes longer to clear
that drug with the
higher concentrations.
And, when metabolic
enzymes are
saturated, a fixed
amount of drug is
metabolized per unit
of time. So, that is
the definition of
zero-order kinetics.
So, check your knowledge
with the adverse
effects. Define the
terms. So, P stands
for P450 and P
glycoprotein interactions.
H stands for hirsutism.
E stands for
enlarged gums,
or gingival hyperplasia.
N is nystagmus.
Y, yellowing of skin,
or jaundice, due
to rare but serious
hepatotoxicity. And
when there's jaundice,
there's elevated
bilirubin, which can
displace the drug
from protein binding
sites. and teratogenicity
with T, fetal
hydantoin syndrome
and osteomalacia
induction of hepatic
vitamin D breakdown,
which will decrease
calcium intake and
lead to softened bones.
I, interference
with folate
absorption and
induction of folate
breakdown and
neuropathies.
Vertigo, ataxia,
nystagmus, we've
seen nystagmus
here two times,
polyneuropathies
with long-term use.
And S,
skin, skin coarsening,
skin reactions,
purple glove syndrome,
skin reactions, we
can think about the
HLA-B star 1502 allele.
And which group?
In certain
Asian groups. And
cardiovascular,
rapid IV administration
or high dose,
phenytoin is a sodium
channel blocker, and
propylene glycol is a
vasodilator and cardiac
depressant. So
conduction abnormalities
can occur, such as
bradycardia, AV block,
QRS widening on the
EKG, ventricular
arrhythmias,
and vasodilation
will cause this
hypotension.
so we'll go through
the next group the
next three more quickly
because they they're
less complicated
although carbamazepine
has complications
of its own so these
are enhancers of fast
inactivation state
i've highlighted
carbamazepine because that's
the one with the star
on it it's important
to recognize how the
others are different,
so I put the takeaways
here at the top.
Carbamazepine is a
strong CYP3A4 inducer
and induces its own
metabolism. It also
induces a number of
other proteins, and
oxcarbazepine and
eslacarbazepine have more
favorable pharmacokinetic
profiles, and
they do not induce
their own metabolism
because they're
not metabolized by
CYP3A4. But they are
inducers of CYP3A4.
Okay, let's look
at carbamazepine.
Oral, that's good.
Mid to high protein
binding, not to the
same extent as we
see with phenytoin.
CYP3A4 metabolism.
Bioavailability
is pretty decent.
Octocarbazepine is
actually a pro-drug.
This is the active
metabolite, which is
actually S-licarbazepine.
There's no S there.
S-licarbazepine.
Oh, look at that.
That's the other drug.
So they have decent
bioavailability,
all of them.
Carbamazepine.
negligible unchanged
drug is excreted
either in the urine
or the feces and
the half-life variable
oh dear variable
half-life because
of auto induction
now that auto induction
generally occurs
over three to five
weeks and then it
plateaus so the patient
can be on a stable
dose after that time.
But in the interim,
as the enzymatic
activity increases,
the dose that is started
with will produce
lower levels as the
weeks go by. So the
dose has to be
gradually increased for
that reason. It's a
pharmacokinetic reason.
here's what else it
induces all of these
CYPs plus the UGT1A1
plus p-glycoprotein plus
this multi-resistant
protein too which is
an efflux pump
plus organic anion
transporter so just
remember high potential for
adverse effects
because of all of this
and therapeutic uses
well caramazepine
is the gold standard
if anything take this
away gold standard
first line option
for the treatment of
focal onset epilepsy
in all ages it is
highly effective plus
evidence we have to
think about evidence
how do we know it's
highly effective It
has been a comparator
in nearly all modern
trials, and it is
widely available,
affordable, and long
clinical experience.
Focal onset seizures,
focal evolving
to generalized tonic
-clonic seizures.
Just that. It's not
effective and may
increase the frequency
of these other
types of primary
generalized seizures.
Plus, it's got some non
-seizure applications,
which I'd like you
to be familiar with.
Trigeminal neuralgia.
That is the
drug that is
generally used for the
management of this
painful facial
aberration.
Trigeminal neuralgia.
Also, for
bipolar disorder.
Management of
hypomania, management of
mania, management of
the major depression
that can come with
bipolar disorder.
Carbamazepine dosing,
please be sort of
generally familiar
with this idea. I'm not
asking you to remember
the exact dosages and
time frames, but get
the idea that it is
increased gradually
based on seizure control,
tolerability, and
serum concentrations.
Seizure control,
tolerability,
and serum concentrations.
Okay, speaking
of tolerability,
well, we've got some very
important HLAs here
to think about.
HLA B1502 phenotype.
therefore certain
populations asian
populations are at
increased risk of
stevens johnson
syndrome toxic epidermal
necrolysis and hla
3101 increased risk
of all of these sjs
t en and d r e s s
hyponatremia spend a
little time on this
hyponatremia is low
levels low serum
levels of sodium. So
how does this happen?
Another acronym
for you, SIADH.
This stands
for Syndrome of
Inappropriate
Antidiuretic Hormone.
Antidiuretic hormone
is made in the
hypothalamus, is
stored in the posterior
pituitary, and it
acts in the kidney.
So what we're talking
about here, at
least as far as has
been identified as
nephrogenic syndrome
of inappropriate
antidiuretic hormone,
meaning it's at the
level of the kidney. So
how does this happen?
Carbamazepine
appears to promote
the insertion of
aquaporins, just what
it sounds like. These
are water channels
and they have a name,
AQP2, and the distal
nephron. This is
a place called the
collecting tubules.
And when those channels
are inserted, free
water gets reabsorbed.
So what is free
water? Free water
just means it's water
without solutes in
it. So that free water
gets reabsorbed and
goes into the capillary
system, into the
systemic system. So
now we have more
water flowing through
the vessels. and
that will reduce the
concentration of sodium
within the vessels.
Hyponatremia and
water intoxication,
too much water,
can occur.
Now the greatest risk is
actually with
oxcarbazepine.
Carbamazepine can
still cause it.
Look at that range.
That depends on
what studies have
been looked at.
And eslacarbazepine
can also cause
it. So all of them
can cause this
hyponatremia and it
should be monitored.
Hematological effects,
bone marrow suppression,
so decreased
synthesis of red and
white cells and platelets,
and proliferative
effects, just
to be confusing.
And the mechanism is
not known. Fortunately,
it doesn't happen
often. It is reversible.
So bottom line,
you just have
to watch for
it. Pregnancy.
Increased
incidence of spina
bifida, craniofacial
defects,
cardiovascular
malformations.
Other agents should
be considered in
patients of
childbearing potential.
Oxcarbazapine doesn't
seem to cause those
effects to the same degree.
It can be considered
during pregnancy.
It is effective for
focal onset seizures.
and the eslacarbazepine
we just don't know
yet there's not enough
data to tell us drug
interactions high
risk numerous what else
i don't need to say
more about that you
should know the mechanisms
of these drug
interactions mechanisms
mechanisms mechanisms
so more pictures on the
left we see stevens
johnson syndrome and on
the right is toxic
epidermal necrolysis
which is just really
an extension of more
serious adverse effects
that extend from SJS.
So check your knowledge.
What are the
meaning and effect
of fast inactivation
enhancers?
Well, physiology of
the sodium channel
is that in less than
a millisecond after
opening and sodium
conduction, the
channel undergoes a
conformational change
with gating that
enters the inactivated
state. So, open and
inactivated, and
that's fast inactivation,
and these drugs
enhance that effect,
stabilizing the
channel in the open
and inactivated state,
and they cause
accumulation during the
repetitive firing
and they bind more
strongly at
depolarized potentials.
So, high frequency
action potentials
are preferentially
inhibited.
Well, preferential
to what?
to the normal
activation, which
is much slower.
What are the
meaning, mechanism,
and effect? of
carbamazepine
auto induction.
Now it's so easy.
It's metabolized by
CYP3A4. It's a strong
CYP3A4 inducer and
so it induces its
own metabolism which
occurs generally
over three to five
weeks of therapy and
then it will plateau
and at that point
the patient can be
on a stable dose.
And what is the
importance of these HLAs?
HLA-B-1502 and HLAA
-3101 phenotypes
are at risk for rash and
severe cutaneous
adverse effects.
What are the
clinical applications
of carbamazepine?
Well, focal
onset seizures,
focal evolving to
generalized tonic
-clonic seizures,
trigeminal neuralgia,
bipolar disorder,
and carbamazepine,
oxcarbazepine,
eslacarbazepine
should be avoided
in what seizure
types and why?
they are ineffective
for the other types and
on top of it they
can worsen absence my
absence or absence
myoclonic and akinetic
seizures and hyponatremia
how does that happen
nephrogenic siadh
these drugs can cause
up regulation or
increased insertion of
these aquaporin type
2 channels into the
distal nephron,
into the collecting
tubules, resulting in
unregulated free water
reabsorption, which
leads to low serum
sodium levels. And
this is a delusional
hyponatremia. What
effects in the
newborn have been
associated with
carbamazepine use
during pregnancy.
Increased
incidence of spina
bifida, craniofacial
defects,
cardiovascular
malformations.
Other agents should be
considered in patients
of childbearing
potential, if possible.
And drug interactions?
Well, it is a strong
inducer of CYP3A4,
2B6, 2C9, 1A2, UGT1A1,
p-glycoprotein,
organic anion
transporters, and so on.
So lamotrigine now,
another enhancer
of fast inactivation
state, plus
it seems to have,
there is evidence
that it has other
mechanisms as well
by inhibiting the
release of glutamate, the
excitatory neurotransmitter,
and aspartate,
which is another excitatory
neurotransmitter,
certainly not as
prevalent as glutamate.
Let's look at the
pharmacokinetics.
This is what you call a
favorable
pharmacokinetic profile.
It's oral, various dosage
forms, so
infants, children,
adults.
Protein binding is
really moderate. it.
Hepatoglucuronidation for
metabolism,
that's about it.
Bioavailability
is 98%. That's for
the immediate
release. And that
is when there are
no other drugs
that are affecting
those enzymes.
And it's excreted
in the urine
as glucuronide
metabolites.
Very little free
drug, if any.
Half-life, really
nice half-life,
24 hours.
Now, I put in red these
concepts you
must remember.
Valproate, you recall,
is an inhibitor of
CYPs of various
enzymes, including UDP
-glucuronacil transferase,
and therefore the half
-life is more than
doubled in patients who
are taking valproate.
So if lamotrigine, which
is frequently used as
an add-on, is given
to patients with
valproate, it really needs
to be slowly, slowly
titrated up. And we'll
talk about why it has
to be so slow, much
slower than the other
anti-seizure drugs.
Now in patients
who are taking an
inducer, the half
-life will be reduced.
And if the patient has
liver insufficiency,
the half-life is
going to be increased.
This all makes sense.
I know you understand
this from your basic
pharmacokinetic
principles that you
learned last term.
Fortunately, there are
color-coded starter
kits available to
help patients to keep
their medication
schedule straight when
they are being initiated
on these drugs.
Oops,
didn't mean to move on.
Therapeutic uses.
Well, this is a
sodium channel
blocker, a fast
activation enhancer.
But recall that
it also has other
activities. So
lamotrigine is actually a
broad spectrum anti
-seizure drug. So
it's effective for
focal onset seizures,
and it's effective
for certain primary
generalized tonic
-clonic seizures.
Effective for
something called
Lennox-Gastaut
syndrome, which is a
childhood epilepsy
encephalopathy.
And for absence
seizures, second
line. First line,
ethosuximide,
valproate if
necessary, and then
lamotrigine if
still necessary.
Non-seizure uses,
bipolar disorder.
However,
it's only for preventing
major depressive
episodes. It's not
really useful for mania,
for preventing mania.
and it needs to be so
slowly introduced, so
slowly titrated, it
cannot be used for
acute bipolar episodes.
Side effects, really it's
pretty well tolerated,
especially compared
to phenytoin. You
get some nausea,
dizziness, drowsiness.
Low incidence
of sedation, it
can occur in
certain patients.
Low incidence of
cognitive side
effects, although
they can occur.
But it can worsen
migraine headaches,
so people who
get migraines
perhaps shouldn't
get lamotardine.
And serious
hypersensitivity
reactions. Here
we have our HLA-B
star 1502 variant
allele again.
and this is what I
absolutely, positively
want to impress on you
that you need to know.
To reduce the
risk of rash,
the drug should
be slowly titrated
over 6 to 8 weeks,
even more cautiously
if added to
valproic acid. Why?
Why? Because valproate
is an inhibitor
of the metabolism
of lamotrigine.
And in fact, the
recommendation is
even lower dose
and every other day
on initiation rather
than every day.
Cosamide now
enhances the slow
inactivation state.
So this one has a
slightly different
mechanism of action.
Yes, it's a sodium
channel blocker.
The slow inactivation
state occurs later
when there has been
pathologic activity
in the sodium channel.
It will slowly
transition over to
this slow inactivation
state, which is a
protective mechanism.
So, licosamide
will actually
stabilize this state.
So it produces a long
-lasting non-conductive
state. And this
appears to be, anyway,
the predominant mechanism
of action of licosamide.
Licosamide also
seems to enhance the
fast inactivation
state. This Mexicanism
has been suggested in
more recent studies.
However, the drug
has what's called
slower binding and
unbinding kinetics.
So it's not exactly
the same as the other
ones we saw. Well,
what's the effect?
It preferentially targets
the pathologically
overactive neurons,
preventing repetitive
firing during
sustained birth without
broadly suppressing
normal brain function.
So it appears to
produce better seizure
control with fewer
generalized side effects.
This drug has
come to the market
more recently, certainly
than phenytoin,
carbamazepine,
and lamotrigine.
Again, really favorable
pharmacokinetics,
oral, IV, minimal
protein binding, hepatic
metabolism with minor
CYP involvement, in
active metabolites, 100
% oral bioavailability,
excreted in urine,
about 40% unchanged,
and the half-life is
approximately 13 hours,
which is pretty good,
twice daily dosing.
It's used for focal
onset and also
primary generalized
onset seizures, mainly
add-on for these,
but it can used as
monotherapy or add
-on for focal onset.
Off-label,
it's being used
occasionally for
status epilepticus.
We do have other
drugs for that.
The benzodiazepines,
which we'll talk
about in the next
lecture, are first line.
Fenytoin,
levotiracetam, and
licosamide are all
potential second agents
adverse effect generally
well tolerated commonly
dizziness drowsiness
cns of course
headache the gait
disturbance ataxia
confusion etc but generally
better tolerated than
say phenytoin pr this
is something different
unique feature pr
interval increase
bradycardia and AV block.
So it's recommended
the patient have an
ECG before starting
this drug to get a
baseline look at their
cardiac function.
Individuals who have
cardiac problems
probably should
avoid this drug, and
there are certainly
other options.
Hypersensitivity
reactions can occur.
SJS and TEN and DRESS
rarely have been
reported, but there
is no evidence of this
HLA-B 1502 variant
allele involvement.
The usual suicidal
ideations and tendencies
have been reported
and associated with
licosamide and drug
interactions, mainly the
CNS effects. We don't
see much in the way
of pharmacokinetic
interactions. So it certainly
seems like easier
to use drug anyway.
So let's take a quick
check on the knowledge.
Mechanisms of action
of lamotrigine
and licosamide are
fast inactivation
enhancer
lamotrigine, slow
inactivation state
enhancer licosamide.
The clinical
significance.
Compared with
carbamazepine, lamotrigine
is effective
for focal onset,
focal evolving to
generalized tonic
-clonic seizures,
and absence seizures
with a better
pharmacokinetic profile.
Titration to therapeutic
dose is slow to
reduce the risk of
severe skin reactions.
Licosamide is used
for focal onset,
focal evolving to
generalized tonic-clonic
seizures, add-on
for refractory
primary generalized
seizures, more favorable
pharmacokinetics
again, adverse
effect profiles
better, and it can be
titrated more rapidly
than lamotrigine.
Why does lamotrigine
have specific dose
requirements when
used as an add-on
agent with valproate
or phenobarbital.
The half-life is
more than doubled
in patients taking
valproate, whereas
when taken with
a strong inducer,
the half-life is reduced.
And this broad
spectrum, meaning it
induces a lot of
proteins. That's what the
broad spectrum means
here. and what are
the lamotrigine
dosing adjustments in
general well valproate
very slow dose
titration it's always
slow but this is even
slower and inducers
initiate at higher
doses but still slow
titration and fortunately
there are kits
color-coded kits
available to help
patients with adherence.
And the physiological
basis of the skin
reactions is HLA
-B1502 for lamotrigine,
and these
patients should be
screened before
starting therapy.
Risk factors for
cardiovascular
adverse effects
of licosamide
is increased PR
interval leading to
bradycardia and AV
block, and I pointed
out this PR interval
on the EKG here.
Skin reactions can occur,
but they're
not associated
with these HLA
variant alleles.
And clinical
applications of the two
drugs, lamotrigine
focal onset, primary
generalized
epilepsy, generalized
seizure, like Lennox
-Gastaut syndrome,
prevention of major
depressive orders and
bipolar, licosamide,
focal onset seizures,
evolving to generalized,
and add-on for
resistant primary
generalized seizures.
So that brings us to
the end. In the interest
of time, I'm not
going to go through
the summary I invite
you to look at it on
the PowerPoint PDF and
I have included the
mechanism here again
and some adverse
effects and the check
your knowledge answers
concludes part one of the
lecture on anti
-seizure drugs